[Applause]
Thank You dr. Spaulding sometimes when I
follow or somebody who has graduated
from CMC after me I think some of us
blaze paths for Greater to follow but no
one can hold a candle to what Matt's
been able to achieve here as well as at
the Heritage Foundation over the last 25
years and we look forward to another
couple of decades of promoting Liberty
as I try and make sure my copy here is
not interrupted by Wi-Fi signals in the
interest of some degree of precision I'm
going to do more reading from prepared
text than I'm want and of course that's
both going to provide some precision but
also avoid some of the questions that
will necessarily come up so I look
forward to addressing the unanswered
questions about the philosophy behind
tariffs and how they interact with
Liberty during our Q&A period but one
thing we should note is that president
Trump's tariffs as have mapped noted has
been roundly attacked from all sides
that in the current economic discourse
of the elite that they're so beyond the
pale that even politically diametrically
opposed editorial boards such as the New
York Times and The Wall Street Journal's
can join forces in condemning this
heresy in fact one might almost expect
that he would have received less
opposition from both editorial boards
had he renounced his Christianity and
denied the divinity of Jesus of course
that might have opened them up for some
criticisms from some other corners but
this unholy alliance of left and right
merely demonstrates how central the idea
behind tariffs the orthodoxy nay the
dogma of free trade is to Trump's
philosophical challenge to the modernity
the very idea that Trump's acts may have
a philosophy it all may strike many as
odd this is not a man who is
particularly articulate in advancing
ideas of theory he is somebody who is
notoriously transactional when it comes
to policy witness
the shifts on North Korea in the last
couple of months changing his mind on a
host of issues with startling speed
unlike past presidents like Ronald
Reagan or George W Bush Trump is notably
unwilling or unable to comprehensively
explain where he wants to take this
country but this does not mean that he
lacks such a vision nor that that one
exists in our American tradition behind
the sort of political economy that he
wants to build in short that vision
which is implicitly Trump's and
explicitly was those of people like
Hamilton that dr. Spaulding spoke of
before rests an idea of a community and
a nation that has fallen into disfavor
among elites particularly those engaged
in the study of wealth production on
both the left and the right Americans in
this view are not simply individuals
whose value is determined by consent or
market transactions they are our fellow
citizens people to whom we have an
obligation that is separate from their
ability to persuade or compel the owners
of capital to invest in their lives when
their dreams cannot be fulfilled or
their lives are harmed because other
Americans make decisions that directly
or indirectly harm them or when direct
intervention in some measure some
limited measure can materially increase
their opportunities and the ability to
live lives of their own choosing then
according to this philosophy it's
legitimate for government to set things
right with such action as dr. Spaulding
noted this is far from a novel vision in
America let's not go back as far as
Hamilton let's simply start with the mid
19th century the Whig party's economic
agenda was explicitly centered on this
notion they differed with the Democrats
of their day and the dimmer descended
from Jackson and Jefferson's Democratic
Republicans precisely over the role of
the federal government in the economy
Whigs believed that the federal
government in order to enhance American
liberty and prosperity ought to favor
manufacture and building in a national
interconnected economy over plantation
agriculture and the dislocated local
economies that were favored by
Democratic Republican
or Jacksonian democratic economic theory
central to this idea was protective
tariffs that for Whigs believe that that
would allow American industry to rise
also central that idea was subsidized
transportation infrastructure roads and
canals at first what Henry Clay called
the American system and which Abraham
Lincoln staunchly supported as a young
wigged lawyer and a young Whig
politician in Illinois railroads as they
became the modus vivendi for speedy
transportation between long distant
locations all this should extend
domestic trade throughout the United
States and hence bind the Union
economically more closely together
tariffs and transportation bill does
that sound familiar Abraham Lincoln
shared this view as I noted and in fact
the first wholly Republican Frederick
government the first government there
was where the Republican Party held the
Senate the house and the presidency
enacted their cardinal measures to
advance this view in the first Congress
that they met they passed four
particular measures each of which
embodied this view that government
action can enhance economic opportunity
and can enhance individual liberty they
passed the Pacific Railroad's Act which
is subsidized the selection of a
Transcontinental Railroad that would
bind east and west and subsequently in
subsequent Republican administrations
they expanded the subsidy of railroads
more generally the land-grant colleges
Act gave federal land or its monetary
equivalent to states that established
universities that also establish
programs in agricultural research MIT
Cornell and the University of California
at Berkeley are only three such colleges
that are noteworthy today but oh they're
creation to the Morrill land-grant
colleges Act the Department of
Agriculture was also created at this
time a year later and again in order to
bring the federal government's hand
directly behind spreading innovative
agricultural research technology to
people who otherwise would not be able
to obtain a using the federal government
to enhance economic opportunity and
Liberty the Homestead Act the most
famous of these acts subsidized
migrations on
western territories by giving away land
to the people who cultivated it in other
words a subsidy and protective tariffs
along the centerpiece of this economic
vision allowed domestic manufacturers
the space to rise nor was this simply a
vision of the early Republican Party
subsequent Republican administrations
and congressional leadership adapted
these principles to meet the challenges
of their age as we saw large businesses
known as trusts or monopolies arise in
the later part of the 19th century the
republican-controlled Congress under the
presidency of Benjamin Harrison passed
the 1st Antitrust Act in 1890 precisely
to give smaller businesses greater
opportunity when we found that people
corporations in the production of food
or in drugs who were no longer known
personally to the people who consumed
them but rather were distant and shipped
their packages and ship their products
across interstate lines we're no longer
producing things that were inherently
safe the Republican Congress under the
presidency of Theodore Roosevelt passed
the Food and Drug Act which established
what would become the FDA and the meat
Practices Act which established federal
government nationwide inspection of food
products to ensure their safety one of
the things I learned when I was
researching my book on Ronald Reagan is
that in his famous interview with Reason
magazine in 1975 one of the points of
contention between his interviewer a
noted libertarian and personal friend of
mine and himself was precisely over the
FDA that the libertarian argued it was
an improper imposition on individuals
and Ronald Reagan arguing that the FDA
was legitimate to prove to protect us
from botulism and other of food borne
diseases that the individual could not
protect himself against through market
action Republican President Dwight
Eisenhower also proposed measures that
became law with support from both
parties that aimed to directly intervene
in the economy most notably the
interstate highway act which created a
modern version of Henry Clay's American
Way a way of sub transportation subsidy
that created greater national economic
ability and thereby whoa
the American economy and through our own
migration the American people more
closely together the view that animates
all of these acts is that it carries
with it a less materialistic and more
spiritual view of what it means to be
human the American can produce something
of value produces far more than the
value of the goods or services that he
produces that person produces pride and
dignity earning enough through one's own
efforts to produce support one's own
life vision in the context of the age in
which you live is the most basic source
of pride for everyone the great were
talented may take pride in other things
such as the ability to best others in
competition or build something outside
themselves like a business or of
creating a work of art but these more
recognized sources of pride including
achievement in producing achievement
ultimately rests on the most common and
basic ability to produce enough of
substance to support oneself and one's
family according to the nature of the
era proud people also want to live in
proud communities they take care of
their surroundings both their personal
homes and the collective that they share
like this has always been a notable
source of home ownership among
working-class people
the people who come to visit and note
how no matter how poor the areas are the
lawns are usually well-kept and houses
well-maintained and then what this is no
longer true when often sees the decline
not only in the area but as the
character of the people who inhabit the
area they want clean and safe streets
attractive buildings and open spaces and
even perhaps some expressions of
communal pride and aspirations such as
those found in monuments public
buildings or our common spaces such as
parks no upper income suburban die who
wants their child going to a school
whose windows are broken or wants to buy
goods in a place where shops are boarded
up the same holds true for everyone in
Trump's view and in the view of many and
especially in the view of millions of
voters or political economy has been
hurting millions of Americans for far
too long
Tradeworks into this because the
international trade agreements that we
have Foster Dover the last 30 years
allow Americans who
as capital whether that capital is
intellectual and the ideas that they
have physical and the things that they
own or monetary simply shifting money
across vast spaces to contract with
foreigners to produce goods or services
at vastly lower prices this system means
American factories that cannot compete
and as anyone who's been through the
Midwest or areas in the south can tell
you there are many such factories closed
or move and the good-paying jobs that
come with those factories dry up for
many people the value that they possess
in the economic sphere comes less from
what they bring to the table and more
from the machines that they operate if
those machines are now operated by
foreigners the jobs that are left to
people of their skills and talent are
not necessarily the same market value
but they remain Americans the owners of
capital benefit enormously that is
what's behind the dramatic increases in
incomes among the most educated
Americans in the last 30 years and is
particularly pronounced among the people
who work in the investment of finance
that people who are involved in
financing these overseas investments are
profiting enormously Americans as a
consumers benefit as well too from the
cheaper goods and services that this
system creates but millions tens of
millions of Americans are net losers
their losses as form of producers far
exceed their gains as consumers nor are
these losses merely material as they
lose their jobs through no fault of
their own
to quote Franklin Roosevelt and Ronald
Reagan their sense of pride suffers as
too many of them lose their jobs all at
once their communities suffer they may
find other work that pays less and man
their families make new but their sense
of being part of a common endeavor dims
as their communities decline into
neglect and disrepair and anyone who's
driven through the back roads off the
interstates of the Midwest and the
mid-atlantic know of what I speak the
belief among them that America isn't
working for them grows current
intellectual orthodoxy treats these
losses as as they might say in the
military collateral damage
the perhaps on
fortunate byproducts of an ever-growing
dare one call it progressive society the
global increase of wealth is valued more
by this orthodoxy than the loss of
income and pride suffered by their
fellow citizens the dramatic increase in
income and life opportunities foreigners
obtained through the system such as the
massive decline in absolute poverty
throughout the third world is touted by
these elites as a great achievement and
let us speak clear so it is but the loss
of both dignity and income by their
fellow Americans is too often overlooked
and ignored this arises because leads on
the right and the left no longer hold no
longer value the sense of nationhood and
community that animated the founders and
animated all generations of political
discussants before the modern era they
no longer believed that community or
citizenship hold enough value to give
rise to political claims to even ask for
protection of jobs of income of the
ability to pursue one's dreams is
unacceptable underneath this course this
is especially I'm afraid true on the
right where to be called a protectionist
is slander in our circles almost on par
with being called a racist society
progresses through the limitless
increase in wealth they murmur at us do
you not understand this view necessarily
carries with it an absolutist vision and
may I say ideological vision of trade
and exchange that if carried to its
logical conclusion undermines the very
idea of American nationality if
government ought never to interfere in
private voluntary transactions on the
grounds that to do so always causes a
decline in economic growth which is of
course the argument one reads ad nauseam
on The Wall Street Journal editorial
page with respect to tariffs and trade
and one of any of the acts that I've
just read you about that have been part
of the National staple of conversation
for over 150 years
what of the workplace safety laws that
we have come to take for granted are
they not interferences and the voluntary
exchange of goods and materiel between
consenting people what of workman's
compensation a mandatory innovative
political compromise that came about
between disputes of owners of capital
labor as industrial society created new
problems with respect to workplace
injury that old common law dictums did
not address the principle advanced by
free trade purest in pursuit of their
international agenda in fact undermines
much more than simply international
trade it undermines the very notion of
government action in the economy to
begin with this view implicitly treats
nationality as either in irrelevant or a
subsidiary consideration it denies that
a nation can in pursuit of a common good
place restrictions upon some of its
members to pursue that common good as
such it subtly undermines as I stand in
front of the expression of Republican
self government itself the
Constitutional Convention it subtly
undermines the idea of Republican
self-government itself which only
derives moral validity from the belief
that common deliberation and debate can
produce a legitimate consensus in
support of a common good which society
then works to enact there are to be sure
many difficulties with this idea one can
say that the whole idea of natural
rights addresses limitations on both the
sorts of ends and the types of means
that a legitimate Republican government
can enact through its deliberative
measures but no one at the founding
would have argued that government ought
not ever to place limits on or otherwise
regulate trade in goods and services the
Constitution itself clearly envisions
that as it explicitly gives Congress the
right to regulate trade with foreign
nations and among the states while
leaving states with the power to
regulate trade within its own borders
and let us make no mistake those powers
were exercised in their respective
spheres from the beginning of the
founding period this was not a complete
libertarian Nirvana prior to the
election of Abraham Lincoln it may be
unwise or as Matt calls it matters of
prudence to regulate trade in certain
manners indeed respect and support for
private initiative and property has
always been a hallmark of our political
economy and not always to remain a form
art of our political economy but the
idea that the government ought never to
regulate those exchanges is alien itself
to that very political
economy the left and right disagree
somewhat on how to address these losses
that people are suffering in this
country to be sure those on the right
unfortunately tend to ignore any
requests for redress as improper if you
ask for a subsidy to maintain a standard
of living if you ask for action in order
to bring some sort of business to your
hometown if you ask for some sort of
requirement of that ensures that your
child doesn't or you don't have lose
access to a doctor many on the right
label you a taker if you're not building
a business or going to college to
improve yourself you're just not worth
enough for us to take notice this let's
not forget is essentially a denial of
the dictum that all men all Americans
have equal Worth and dignity it's no
accident to the very people who flocks
to Donald Trump that made what was
called the blue Midwestern wall red that
turned their backs on the romney-ryan
ticket nor is it surprising when we look
at their entire history of going back
since the Industrial Age the Republican
Party was once the party of immigrants
it was once the party of the blue-collar
worker it was that party when the system
of Henry Clay and Abraham Lincoln's
political economy ruled the day it was
the time when you could go to Chicago
and meet Republican mayor's when
Republican candidates carried Pittsburgh
and when miners and loggers voted for
the party of the elephant that ended
with the Great Depression when Herbert
Hoover argued that nothing in the
Constitution allowed him to directly
intervene in the economy on the scale
that would prevent or even begin to
seriously ameliorate this say the
suffering that was felt by over half of
America's people they then turned their
backs on the party of the elephant on
the party that once promised a full
dinner pail and turned to the Democrats
and since that time they have continued
to support the party that adopts the
sort of principles that Henry Clay and
Abraham Lincoln adopt one that allows
for free action and free enterprise and
the ability of the ambitious to move up
while also providing sufficient protect
so that the gains from trade are fairly
shared and that all people of all
talents can live dignified lives of
their choosing they will back
Republicans who support these of
principles even as they offer wildly
different interpretations of them than
their more liberal or progressive foes
Dwight Eisenhower used to say when he
talked about how he approaches that he
was a liberal in human matters but a
conservative in fiscal matters which
meant that he was willing to have a
limited expansion of some degrees of
government involvement certainly never
government ownership or government
direction Ronald Reagan himself was
somebody who never rejected these ideas
and as I argue very clearly in my book
that way that you can understand
Reagan's movement from being an ardent
backer of Franklin Roosevelt to being
what he became was precisely that he
never abandoned the idea that people
ought to have a hand up in American life
but not a handout he was an interpreter
a radical interpreter to be sure but an
interpreter not an opponent of this
principle the left tends to fail in a
way that's even more problematic it does
so by looking at these people at our
citizens at our fellow neighbors as
merely material beings to them the
problem is lack of money consequently
increased government subsidies
particularly through checks sent by the
government things like uniform basic
income or enhanced minimum wage hikes or
other forms of direct monetary
alleviation will solve the problem but
the fact is neither solution confers the
pry that comes from a job nor does
either solution address the system that
places these people under a continual
competition that they simply cannot win
they are merely palliatives
a hospice if you will that ease the
suffering of the body but ignore the
suffering of the soul and overlook the
possible death of both Trump solutions
which are identical to the Republican
platform of 1928 and 1932 tariffs and
immigration restriction ring true too
many Trump voters because they directly
press what they perceive as the causes
of their problems my research showed
that years
for Trump ever showed up on the stage if
you ask people who were the sort of
person who switched from Obama to Trump
what they thought about trade and what
they thought about Wall Street they
extort an immigration they endorse
exactly the positions that Donald Trump
mirrored back at them four years later
when he came down the escalator at his
Trump Tower such direct action however
has the additional perhaps even the
decisive benefit of telling these voters
telling these Americans that they matter
just as one derives pride from living in
a well-kept local community someone also
derives pride from living in a country
that recognizes and even perhaps exalts
your values as their own for many of
these people that more than any
immediate or tangible increase in their
income is what will make America great
again I'm often asked by the laughs
people on the left well what if these
voters don't what they don't see things
improve what if Trump's ideas don't
deliver and I've come to realize that as
long as they don't get are moving
backward as long as Trump is delivering
reassurance as long as Trump is
delivering a belief that they are part
of this fight that they are part of the
American discussion which they've not
felt for a very long time they will stay
with him because that is what they value
now tariffs may not produce the desired
results in increasing job numbers
shrinking international trade may very
well produce a shrinking global economy
that causes Americans to lose jobs and
become poor they may be a bad means to
enact a proper end but on the other hand
tariffs may be simply a precursor to a
deal that spreads the gains from
increasing wealth in international trade
more evenly between foreign labor
capital and American labor that's what
Ronald Reagan's trade error restrictions
did in many many ways and while we tend
to remember Ronald Reagan as a free
trader and that is certainly true he
loved free trade and advanced free trade
agreements and was in fact the father of
the idea that became NAFTA announcing
that what he called a North American
common market in his introductory
address when he became president entered
into the 1980 presidential race
in government Ronald Reagan frequently
deviated from free-trade purist
ideological orthodoxy he pushed the
Japanese to adopt voluntary export
restraints on automobiles voluntarily
adopted quotas under the threat that if
you didn't do it yourself the Congress
might force us to do it on you he pushed
for the same idea on machine tools
he created limits on semiconductor
imports and they were threatening to
destroy the American hi-tech industry in
its infancy he allowed for the creation
and by looking at the possible violation
of antitrust laws to allow semiconductor
companies to pool their resources for
research in a consideration called
SEMATECH and perhaps most importantly in
a way that we can understand and in our
daily life he saved harley-davidson
motorcycle company and this is a story
that I'm gonna tell a little more in
detail because it's one that he's tells
in detail in his autobiography in
American life but in the early 1980s as
he calls as the executive
harley-davidson came to him and said
that they couldn't compete with unfairly
subsidized and unfairly promoted
Japanese motorcycle imports if they gave
him two years however through sanctions
on an import quotas on the Japanese
motorcycles they could retool their
company and compete and Reagan's telling
he complied and they comply as Reagan
says one year later they came back and
said we finished the job earlier you can
take the sanctions off now
so Rankin did take the sanctions off and
in his book he talks about pride of how
his action saved an American company
because he believed that with fair
competition no one could out produce the
American worker so every time you look
at a Harley Davidson and picture and
television are running down the street
remember that company exists today
because Ronald Reagan violated free
trade orthodoxy to ensure that Americans
of all backgrounds had a fair stake in
American life but in a very important
sense economics is not the way that we
should measure the success of these
measure of these provisions it is
certainly an important way it is a
crucial way but it's not necessarily the
decisive way
that we should engage success of this
that is because so-called populist
movements throughout the world are
gaining strength precisely because their
voters no longer feel values members of
their Nations we can see this and things
like brexit and the way that the Italian
voters continually have thumbed their
noses at the bipartisan elite that
wanted to curry favor with Brussels we
can see it in a host of political
parties that are gaining strength in
Europe that they do not believe they're
worth should decline because the owners
of capital say so or that because of the
Lords of business say so or that the
Lords of the media or the politics say
so nor do they think that their life
dreams or value should be denigrated
simply because them educated most
educated have different visions populous
overseas tend also if not to be highly
religious like Americans tend to be more
socially conservative and less
comfortable with the enforced drift
towards social progressivism that is too
often advanced without consideration by
the elites in their capitals populous
like Trump addressed this spiritual
yearning and fulfill the deepest need
every human has to be valued and to
belong to a group that values you in
this and perhaps in this sense alone all
men are truly created equal tariffs are
simply an economic means to fulfill this
spiritual need tariffs opponents can
only win if they first recognize this
need and recognize its legitimate
routing in the American political and
constitutional tradition and promise a
more effective way to fulfill it there
are many ways that we can adopt that can
give people the private-sector jobs they
crave and thereby give them the pride
and dignity that they deserve things
like increased vocational technical
education in Germany and Switzerland
their programs have ensured that people
of lesser skills still get jobs in
today's economy as opposed to America
system that tells people that if you
don't go to college you're a failure and
then sets up millions of people for whom
succeeding at college is merely a pipe
dream for failure and dropping out
failure in student loans they can't
repay and failure in jobs that they can
never fill
perhaps a more effective vocational
education program will do more to
restore America's sense of community and
have restore some of these problems than
tariffs ever will
mobility grants or what I call in one
article a new Homestead Act people are
trapped in job deserts by a host of
things some of them private such as home
values that they have declined below
what they pay for them they simply
cannot afford to move the places with
greater opportunity or in many cases
government programs that if you were on
an unemployment insurance you are
neither told about nor encouraged to
look for jobs outside of a 50 or 75 mile
radius of your hometown in many places
there aren't those jobs within 50 or 75
miles there may be jobs 500 or 750 miles
away you may be you may need to move
from northern Michigan to southern Texas
but there's nothing that the government
does when they provide help that tells
you about this and that subtly
encourages people to stay put
mobility grants information and other
things that would make benefits portable
across state lines can encourage people
to move in pursuit of opportunity to
move as the people in the 1870s and
1880s did from the ports of the east to
the lands of the West so that they can
provide self they can provide for
themselves and that consequently can
drive that pride that comes from an
honest day work in pursuit of an honest
job
if however tariffs opponents do this
then Trump has already won because the
battle is not over tariffs the battle is
over this because in order to do this
you have to recognize the common
humanity the common nationality the
common citizenship of America you have
to abandon the materialistic view that
says only goods of the body-count you
must recognize that Goods of the soul
that human equality counts too and that
that's part of the legitimate political
discourse and that view is very American
in a very conservative view let me close
with some rare thoughts about the
greatest Americans and
greatest Republicans and the greatest
conservatives Abraham Lincoln and Ronald
Reagan that Lincoln said in an undated
fragment that his definition of
democracy was simple as I would not be a
slave so I would not be a master in that
view liberation of the slaves political
Liberty a free-market economy and an
active but limited government program to
ensure that those gains are spread and
encouraged evenly are not in discrete
elements they are part of a single
unified worldview that as I would not be
a slave that is dependent on someone
else so I would not be a master who
forces that person to work in a way that
injures their pride dignity and ability
to provide for themselves all men are
created equal in this way because then
all people are given the legitimate
opportunity to pursue their talents and
this I believe is what Lincoln meant
when he extolled government of the
people by the people and for the people
before modern age let's consider the
greatest conservative of our lifetime
Ronald Reagan if you go to visit his
grave in the sunny hills of Southern
California where I'm almost out of
central casting at his funeral he was
buried to a cloudless sunlit sky at
sunset you will find his last thoughts
the words he meant to have us remember
him by they are not from one of his
greatest speeches you will not read some
of the great words that he spoke in his
endorsement a very cold war nor will you
read some of the great words that he
delivered at the Westminster address nor
will you here see that he was the person
who brought down the Berlin Wall through
his staunch defense of freedom at a time
when the West was wavering rather you
will read what I believe to be the core
of his philosophy and that is simple and
it is profound but it is not what we
might expect what that epitaph says is
that I believe in my heart that man is
good that what is right will eventually
triumph and that there is Worth and
purpose to each and every human life
litical economy that adopts that as its
central Creed is one that respects the
dignity of freedom but also respects the
dignity of the soul is one that as
Ronald Reagan believed one that enhanced
the maximum degree of ordered Liberty
that is possible in the human society
but not a disordered Liberty that comes
from an unordered a non structured a non
political Liberty and so too I think
that is our choice today we are faced
with the battle of twin material isms
that view people very differently than
the founders did they are people who
will ask us to consider our human value
as reducible either to what the state
tells us or what the owners of capital
tells us and it is against that view
that Americans must fight it is against
that view that Donald Trump is fighting
and if we are successful in this victory
if we are successful in reclaiming our
legitimate political inheritance if we
are successful in reclaiming our own
political tradition then we can as
Ronald Reagan would tell us rest happy
because we will have restored America as
the last great hope of man on earth
thank you
[Applause]